welcome to this video play the master
lsv Stephenie Meyer German I am yeah I
know I'm a platen more than once it's
very low rated yep is a very decent i am
24 something rating so some rather low
rating ok we get the triangle and his
plate them quickly takes e4 in fact this
move order isn't very precise so let's
see if I can can take any advantage
other that's ok c 5
no def 6595 intending night before this
is this is not so great maybe I should
try to provoke some weaknesses on on the
queenside especially a 6 let's see and
the queen is not really really well
placed on now on c2 opposite the rook
interesting acer is a very um
resourceful tactical player if if needed
hmm maybe d phi e md5 let's try that
then often does good answer to to c5
opening up the center let's see I
haven't calculated here don't want to
fall too much behind on the clock this
is of course the problem you need to
retreat to e 2 which is not really a
great square but anyway let's see p 5 is
hanging so it's not like I'm losing d
phi for for nothing
yeah probably can just play a 6m but
rookie one I'm threatening rookie one
here yeah yeah he needed to get rid of
this so that he can quickly get out of
the middle let's let's just take him and
now see for Sam is the weakness let's
show chief I've made him home yeah many
many possibilities trying to provoke f6
which is really an ugly move wanting to
all night Knight f6 I thought Queenie
for but that's not really a problem
interesting
okay twin c4 is taking a live too that's
uh yeah I should go here actually this
is good attacking d7 so he cannot cancel
due to the 19 and this prepares Bishop
c4 amongst others
if you place Knight f6 mmmm I have no
grievance against that I can take c4
maybe I should just just do that but
it's not not completely convincing this
rock on see aid I wonder if I have some
tactical trick to take use of this rook
something something nice I don't see it
okay let's take that I don't see a
better move at the moment Oh came and
now I thought to specialty three using
this battery ask if not before
okay come just develop down to two
minutes not quite sure why I spent this
this time one
yeah f2 cannot play an easy move like
like rookie one can protect them protect
the bishop
maybe I should play Bishop edge for
covering f2 may be difficult he's taking
is taking a sweet time now I know why
its rating is it's not so highs even
slower than me which is to add something
yeah i played this to protect f2
allowing rookie one and let's do that so
that if I've is protected and I can play
maybe not g five yeah I still have an
extra pawn and therefore maybe I'm
slightly better but it's nothing
particularly great okay let's let's get
I get ahead here it's not really
threatening so we can go to e7 to be
honest yeah it's not clear what this is
actually doing okay
do I have something better than I
connect i can do that and get the five
at the end this is probably better than
two going to f3 rook takes Bishop d5 was
my idea no no I'm done running c5 well
that's nice
yeah just to win winning c5
black resigned young this was some
rather sudden end to this game and I
don't know virat yet sides and it's very
interesting but it seems that white is
better due to this ideas on the e-file
hard to sell I mean probably could have
defended better somewhere this moment I
only have this BB porn as my as my extra
point it's not like why should should
win instantly I think probably yeah the
computer says equal yeah well based on
some technical thing probably but it
shouldn't be a really big deal and here
what was the problem up here i just made
a mistake he can take on any form with
the rockin i completely ignored this
possibility i can take with look like
that interesting yeah I can play Bishop
g5 and sort of continued but it's
completely unconvincing of course yeah
black hair black is fine here of course
yeah I didn't see that at all this now
should be quite nice but of course I
don't need to I don't understand the
comp evaluation at all computer wants to
play Queen e7 and says about equal why
am I not winning because of this move
wow wow
equal computer says equal and wants to
play rookie five maybe this is the only
playable move even yeah many ways to
lose their check for example this check
check check mate is a direct way to lose
it yeah I cannot remove the edge
collimated a three mesas is a mate this
is also also lost check yeah the back
rank so probably probably really this
one not sure if I would have found it
actually with limited time yeah this is
just a draw I mean this is this is no no
real porn porn then I have him hmm so we
resigned in the draw position but ok he
had little time and didn't see the
resource alright thanks for watching